this photograph here you're probably
thinking why have I shown you a picture
of a sort of suburban street it happens
to be in Blackpool which is quite
interesting for this discussion because
what it shows is a big crack that goes
just underneath my name there and that
crack was very famous in Blackpool for a
short time because it ported Lee
appeared after an earthquake which was
related to fracking rather nearby that
it's fracking for shale gas hydraulic
fracturing and people said that the
frack had appeared the crack it appeared
in the bridge and people also said that
motorbikes had fallen over than that and
the traffic lights stopped working and
things like that and a lot of people
said and yes the crack appeared and it
was for caused by the fracking now the
bgs detected this earthquake and our
view was there's no way that the energy
of the earthquake could have caused that
Kraken and in fact if you read the
article which was attached to this
photograph if you got knocked down to
the bottom it said an old black ball man
said in fact that crack has been there
since 1972 so and but this this
characterizes the argument of shale gas
that there's an awful lot of stuff going
on which you can't tell is true or false
and this it's rather got worse
unfortunately this is a game black ball
and black will arnett there are people
saying on websites that Blackpool the
coaster black ball is at risk of sinking
below sea level and our seat sea
defences will have to be rebuilt
essentially there is no foundation
whatsoever to this it simply won't
happen